Random Acts program 2 the pirate program
titled the parable of the pirate and the
King
the first two episodes introduce you to
this parable about nausea and Terence
moving through their healing processes
of maintaining themselves and their
relationship which lead them back to
Ritual clearly this particular ritual
isn't working for you the expectation
should not be that I'm gonna like
instantly heal from like a voice
syndrome a lot of the parable is what it
looks like for them to be in connection
with each other while they're fully
committed to their own healing path what
ritual is required nausea and Terence
they got different problems they got
different wounds as they say a lot of
those wounds don't have anything to do
with each other
parents told you not to [ __ ] with that
chill Mandy is very sentient wound who
you are is a story you tell yourself
about what has happened to your body
over time Mandy is that once characters
identify their wounds name them
understand that they're alive then I
think they face the thing that we all
face which is what are you here to teach
me and what we always be here to teach
me given that who you are today won't be
who you are tomorrow
[Music]